[Musique]
messieurs nous sommes dans votre café
tabac lors du déjeuner est un petit peu
le coup de fait je réponds disiez ce que
vous servez le plus savant clients que
mange t il vos clients 210 geoplin de
pour toucher 200 dans mon bar c'est
surtout les sandwichs messieurs pourrait
savoir comment vous nourrissez bas en
général un petit sandwich le midi et
avec quoi comme boisson de la bière et
pensez vous que ce soit bon pour votre
santé pas nécessaire qu'il se trouve
l'important winch ou du fromage point
gâteau comme maintenant et pensez vous
que ce soit une bonne habitude
trois noms cette mauvaise habitude mais
quoi
ça lui ferait ça change un peu partout
des retards pas tous les joueurs mangent
à la cantine vraiment chez moi mais
c'est un accident survenu deux voilà et
votre femme plein régime
monsieur je voudrais savoir comment vous
vous nourrissez à midi à la gabelle
vous êtes là sur un chantier et tous les
jours vous déjeunez comme ça le jour
et qu'est ce qu'il ya dans cette gamme
elle abat ya encore un peu d'alico
devoir de patates
voilà c'est toujours le même menu du
jour toujours mais à la gamme r non
seulement et qu'est-ce qui la préparent
cette gamelle c'est ma femme qui at-il
dedans on baissa dépendent les jours
coincé devant ma femme risque vous
prépare vous préférez quoi voilà préféré
vraiment il n'ya pas tellement de façons
fait tout ce qu'on côtoie tout ce qu'il
m'a fait pas mais la disparité où la
vérité est que le bateau ne savait pas
en voir pensez vous que ce soit bon pour
votre santé 1 2 actuellement je pense
pas ma femme ne veut bien mais bien
obligés quand même monsieur comment vous
nourrissez vous à midi
une fois encore les poissons pour le
bien et la aujourd'hui vous faites cuire
quoi et vous préférez quoi la gamelle ou
faire cuire vos poissons tout seul alors
que les poissons
pourquoi est ce que vous pensez parfois
à votre régime au nom sur mon bras parce
qu'on devrait vos goûts et vos bons mois
je vous êtes toujours en bonne santé
oui et le soir votre femme vous fait
quoi a dîné dessous pour les coins du
musée parce qu'on est étranger pour ça
et et deux fois hommage dans un des bons
mois je compose
tous les jours pareil à n'ont pas tous
les jougs la loi je voulais que toyota
lotir autre chose alors qu'est-ce qui
vous prépare ça sur moi mes bras et
qu'il a acheté votre femme
oui et le soir que vous fait-elle pour
dîner achat sur ma femme at il opère et
c'est bon ce qu'elle fait a bien su que
c'est bon vous n'avez jamais été au
régime a des fois oui pourquoi pas parce
que des fois il se remet à l'eau froide
et croyez vous que ce que vous mangez là
c'est bon pour votre santé
alors moi j'y crois que c'est bon vous
préférez cela au sandwich
ah oui messieurs c'est vous qui vous
occupez des repas de la maîtrise du
chantier et que préparez-vous de bombes
un peu tout ce qui me passe par la tête
est-ce que les menus sont variés oh oui
autant possible
et est ce que ces messieurs qui
travaille toute la journée sur le
chantier vous demande d'aimer des menus
spéciaux ou non pour porter que j'ai
entendu aucun de ces messieurs net au
régime
oui conduite aurait parole à monsieur e
mail à bord et que lui faites vous de
spécial on règle la viande grillée c'est
tout problème de régime à savoir manger
énormément de grillades
surtout ce point là c'est tout pourquoi
pour votre santé pour avoir la ligne et
non pour ma santé avant tout alice est
tout à fait secondaire surtout la santé
dans l'idéal bas le régime le régime
vous savez ça c'est le pouvoir manger
tout souvent plus fréquemment du poisson
évidemment qu'on peut pas faire ici
passion nous sommes obligés tout de même
de de faire des repas de préparer des
repas assez vivement
alors donc on ne peut jamais avoir le
même régime aussi celui qui à la maison
de manger vous et comment se nourrissent
et vous sens elle débutait bien cuit et
est ce que veux tu me fais attention
repas qu'elle voudrait pas souffrance
elle vous fait des menus équilibrés
j'espère j'espère que pensez-vous de la
diététique c'est ce qu'il ya de mieux je
pense vous visez tous les matins au nom
du tout ce que nous faisons tous les
matins non madame n'est pas être vous
faites attention à ce que vous mangez
absolument comment vous mangez tous à
condition que ce soit très frais et pas
de graisse vous faites attention la
diététique ça ça moi je ne mange plus et
bien justement vous êtes un petit peu
encore plus l'eau est ce que vous suivez
un régime 8 g chelle quel régime au
litre de vin par jour
ah c'est pas mal et puis vous croyez la
diététique mais j'ai cru et à la
mâchoire ou le suivant de prison mais le
rav vous avez toute la vie devant vous
avez vous déjà suivi un régime
oui lequel bas régime pour maigrir n'a
pas été très concluant
pourquoi vous n'avez pas la ligne pas du
tout non mais alors que faites vous
ben
pas grand chose à dire moi j'ai trop
vous croyez je crois oui
quatre femmes le sort pourrait perdre
bon dîner oui c'est ça très bonne
cuisinière
alors que faut-il faire suivre des
règles diététiques oui je crois que
c'est indispensable
et pourquoi ne faites-vous pas bas parce
que ça me vaut d'être négligents on vit
dans un monde
on est très négligent la vérité tout va
très bien je mange très bien chez moi ce
que je digère très bien et votre mine
c'est important la ligne
on attendait à mon âge maintenant à
je prends un peu de toi tu d'accord mais
enfin
je peux pour dire comme ça je suis très
bien moi je fais du sport c'est tout
mais non c'est non pas tel pas voir
régulièrement
et la plage en maillot de bain des
français oui mais ça ne m'inquiète pas
je peux tenir
[Musique]